at a high level in phase one which
starts
1201 am february 14th
we'll allow events again increase
gathering limits and business capacity
limits and remove border restrictions
and in phase two gathering and capacity
limits will increase again
and in phase three there will be no more
gathering or capacity limits and we will
also lift physical distancing
requirements
and for now masks are still required in
indoor public places and proof of
vaccination is still necessary for
discretionary activities
and we will let our evolving
epidemiology guide us when we can safely
change these two components
today though i can give some certainty
i'll give you more details about phase
one as i said it starts 1201 am february
14th
so in
in this first phase the informal
gathering limit will increase to 25
people from 10 and they can be from the
same household or consistent social
group
typically this is for gatherings at
people's homes
we will also increase the formal
gathering limit to 50 percent of the
capacity of a venue
and allow a range of events again things
like funerals wedding receptions
festivals fundraisers and fundraisers
and other special events
performances and sports games will be
allowed including when they take place
as part of school extracurricular
activities
and the limit for participants like
players or performers will will increase
to 60 and that's for both sports and
arts and culture uh
performances on games spectators will be
allowed again following the formal
gathering limit
and that formal gathering limit will
also apply to regular faith services
performers like choirs will follow the
limit for arts and culture participants
and we recommend that choirs keep their
masks on for singing in phase one
congregations can sing again but the
mask requirement will remain in place
for them during phase one
retail stores and malls can operate at
maximum capacity possible with physical
distancing
fitness recreation leisure facilities
businesses and organizations can operate
at 75 capacity
so this includes everything from gyms
and arenas to libraries and museums to
dance lessons and dog training
bars and restaurants can operate at 75
percent capacity they they will still
need to have the distance of two meters
between tables and there will be a limit
of 25 people
maximum at a single table
and they'll be able to stay open one
hour later providing table service now
until midnight and closing at 1 1am
they can continue to operate take out
delivery and drive through
for later hours however
and any performers that
follow the limits for arts and culture
participants that are those are
performers within within a licensed
facility
in our public schools enhanced public
health measures such as classroom
cohorts and masking will continue
but singing and the use of wind and
brass instruments can resume
schools will now be allowed to resume
all extra curricular activities
following community guidance for sports
arts and culture
and in long-term care the key changes
that residents can have now any two
visitors at a time
uh we were still we were restricting it
to uh only two and they had to be
consistent visitors but as of monday
they will no longer need to be the same
to two visitors but a maximum of two at
a time and the visitors must still wear
masks and be fully vaccinated except for
end of life and other compassionate
visits
i know that this is a lot to digest and
everyone's tired of trying to learn a
new set of rules
but this is a major step in the right
direction a step towards some more
normalcy in our lives